[Música]
rió Amazonas
de Barreiras
fue bloqueado por la autoridad ambiental
del país y el
rodeado de miembros de la
entorno gubernamental y que en este
prioriza lo económico para su análisis
teléfonos celulares en Foz do Iguaçu en Brasilia
Fábio director latinoamericano de
economía, sociedad y política federal
de la integración latinoamericana
Hola
muy
presentado como este tipo de figura
ambientalistas durante el predecesor de
Jair Bolsonaro tambarenas ambientales
su presidente economista
Si la empresa es un dilema para el gobierno
Brasileño esta pregunta para no
Debería ser que tenga un masónico.
muy complejo entonces lo usas
a los puntos centrales es lo necesario
para que estos recursos sean algo
extraterrestre para vivir en mi vida
de ellas personas que viven allí y una de ellas
críticas que normalmente equivalen a
de los proyectos amazónicos es que no son
escuchar a las poblaciones locales si hay alguna
toda la planificación del Distrito
Federal de la capital de Brasil con la
especialistas que rara vez han estado en
Amazon Así que este ya es un tema.
Durante muchos años esta crítica siempre ha sido
que no es o en su participación
sociedad civil organizada de
Los lugares donde fueron explorados.
Te preguntas por qué esto vuelve a eso.
primer gobierno de Lula porque había
también un dilema entre Marina Silva que
ya era
registros del entorno en su
primer gobierno en 2013 y Dilma
Rousseff, quien fue Ministra de Minas y
energías y en este momento
Lula se puso del lado de priorizar
problemas ambientales entonces, ¿cómo se
Alguien lo dicta en su introducción.
informando que tendrán un dilema difícil para
El gobierno brasileño
tipo ¿Y cómo se compara con el
beneficios económicos La Corte y
Americano
en estudios de impacto ambiental
muchas veces
necesitan mucho tiempo y luego algo de tiempo
inauguración de obras quien pueda en
tratar de dar una respuesta a corto plazo a
promesas de campaña para que estos
precisamente por los estudios medioambientales
A veces cabalgamos en el ion con fe en el amor y
fuerte que son estudios en parcial entonces
Entonces este sentido donde creo que está
calienta con mucho cuidado espéralo
tiempo necesario para estudiar
concluyó Y luego el gobierno brasileño
ya que quieren esto en el nivel de tiempo
Internacional
esta responsabilidad y que sólo tienes que
calentar muy sabio de nuestra parte acelerar
Las obras de Pedro ya han alcanzado un nivel muy
positivo, creo que estas instituciones
el medio ambiente está funcionando y realmente
Ministerio del Medio Ambiente e Ibama
cual es el organismo responsable de
inspección de obras y
autorización de obras por entendimiento
algunos momentos opiniones diferentes de el
propio gobierno así que vamos a esto
significado o institucionalidad
positivo ahora no tiene por qué significar que
Nunca te propongas ser lo que puedas ser
trabaja allí población
realmente necesito montar las obras de
la infraestructura necesita empleos
Ah hay que tener mucho cuidado
estas estas inversiones estos proyectos
No seas más dañino que los beneficios.
posible
coicione privada y senadora Ferreira
Congreso Nacional
Siempre es una frase temática, no es fácil.
Guardé esto casi y me gustan los problemas.
dicen y como se posicionan
las políticas pueden ir el cambio será un
reto muy grande para el gobierno
Lula mantiene la colisión pareja
construido en el que
Esta decisión vino con mucha preocupación.
en
Senador a abandonar ese mismo partido que
era la fiesta de marina silva para tenerme
Creo que esto significa más apoyo.
al gobierno y al mismo tiempo o por la fuerza
su institucionalidad entonces si
por un lado, por supuesto, uno en las crisis,
diferentes perspectivas y que SAS estaban
En la ansiedad de que las galas funcionen más.
lo antes posible con los resultados
positivo
positivo por otro lado creo
que la institucionalidad de
Ibama y la fuerza de Marina Silva
A diferencia de él, el primer gobierno
Lula parece que era el momento de Dete ner more
fuerza y ​​poeta y no solo ser es un
formalidad y si no entendieron nada
para proteger también a la masonería Pero
no ser completamente
crear obstáculos a cualquier tipo de
obras que pueden resultar interesantes para
la población local también
que por un lado es un digamos un
fortalecimiento de las instituciones que
fueron destruidos durante un período de Bolsonaro
y con mucho deterioro del lenguaje
Brasil en el extranjero, entonces tú ahí fuera
Brasil jugaría un papel destacado en
daño ambiental claramente
Sin embargo Sigue y con muchos problemas de
No puedo hacer mi tarea así que vete
que demuestran claramente que traemos
las instituciones están siendo
reforzado incluso mejorado un
uso de memoria no extrapuesto a
supervisión y para la recopilación de datos y
por otro lado, también es necesario
estudio científico serio para también
que no puedes ser nada si puedes ser
muchas cosas para Ai que estar con grandes
tecnología es lo que significa estar con estudios
confiable y creo que en este sentido
Brasil tiene que demostrar que tuvo
verdadera preocupación por la masonería porque
las instituciones internacionales
otros países, por un lado, vieron allí
El ascenso de Lula como en la reanudación
de estas inquietudes nos permitirá cobrar un
seriedad de su gobierno brasileño en
Con respecto a esto también, entonces será
mucho cuidado para demostrar claramente
que las cosas van por el camino
correcto
todo el lado americano de la economía
sociedad y política federal
Integración latinoamericana Monte
Reconocimiento
[Música]